how's it going everyone we have some new
leaked photos of x-men dark phoenix from
the reshoots that they're doing in
montreal canada quick reminder that the
infinity war blu-ray giveaway continues
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber like this video and comment
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero so as you see here we
have sophie turner playing Jean Grey
Jessica Chastain as the mysterious
villain that has not been confirmed yet
and if you look you can see Cyclops over
to the right
not much context for these photos except
for the fact that we know Jessica
Chastain is going to play the main
villain of the movie and this scene
appears to be her attacking Jean Grey
Cyclops is over to the side but doesn't
really appear to be in the scene so
maybe he got taken out of the fight
somehow or maybe he just thinks that
Jean has it all under control so much
has happened with this movie the release
date getting pushed back and especially
the rumors of it being trashed after the
Disney Fox acquisition and then doing a
lot of reshoots but it does seem like
things are under way and it's gonna come
out next year hopefully as time gets
closer we'll learn a little bit more
about this mysterious villain that
Jessica Chastain is playing for awhile
it was speculated that she would play
lilandra the Shiar empress from the
classic Dark Phoenix saga
it is now however believed that she will
be playing Miss sinister who is a
version of the x-men villain mr.
sinister who in the comics has a strong
tie with both Cyclops and Jean Grey it
still remains to be seen but as of right
now x-men Dark Phoenix still stands to
come out on February 2019 so it looks
like we will have to wait until then in
the meantime let me know your thoughts
on these new leaked photos and again the
giveaway continues all you have to do is
subscribe like this video and comment
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero thank you so much for
watching Wolf Wolf
[Music]